we're going to begin this hour though
with a segment of Prince Harry's 60
Minutes interview that you may not have
heard before the Duke of Sussex spoke
with Anderson Cooper about his new
Memoir spare last night on 60 Minutes
and he revealed that he's not speaking
to his brother Prince William and he
remembered how he learned that Princess
Diana had died in this clip from 60
Minutes over time Harry says he
understood his mother better after he
became a father
having been through what you've been
through now
do you understand your mom differently
in what sense in a deeper way what she
was going through I think one thing I've
realized about grief and loss is that
one's relationship with somebody who's
died continues and your understanding of
them
actually can change over time having
been through what you went through with
the family with your wife the Press do
you understand your mother from a
different angle over the years I have
understood it more but yes certainly as
a as a parent
to two little kids
I'm starting to comprehend the position
that she was in as a mother single
parent trying to look after two boys
with this intense media harassment it
wasn't online then it was very much
physical she was being chased for the
majority of her life when she got
together with my father it got so much
worse after the divorce so I've done and
continue to do everything I can to make
sure that that doesn't happen to my
family because it certainly doesn't seem
as though the British press have changed
their ways
and she was literally chased CBS News
Royal contributed that's Tina Brown
joins us she's in London this morning
good morning to you Tina I can't wait to
hear what you have to say what you're
hearing what you're feeling what you're
thinking I know you watched Anderson's
interview and certainly the ITV
interview both ran last night what stood
out to you and did you see a difference
between the American interview and the
interview in the UK
well I think what obviously was deeply
moving in both was to hear about the
agony of this young child that lost his
mother you know there's no doubt that I
think what he said to Amazon about how
he you know pretended to himself or
believed that his mother might come back
that she hadn't really died
uh was incredibly touching because it's
what a child does they live with magical
thinking their mommy's going to come
back so that I found enormously moving
but when he starts to move in both the
interviews and when he moves into what's
been happening in the last few years
then I start to feel that Harry's doing
some gaslighting himself frankly because
the fact is that you know here he is
like selling out his family for money
essentially when he's talked so often
about the agony of being betrayed he
also you know he was quite happy to have
the palace spin on his behalf when it
suited him because as he describes you
know he was doing a tremendous amount of
drugs he was totally out of hand you
know he was really out of control and
yet the palace had to go out and sort of
clean up after him and spin and kill
stories and make things go away they
were always doing that for Harry so he
doesn't acknowledge that there's a
two-way street here and finally you know
when I was uh reporting my book The
Palace papers I I talked to so many
people who were so close to William and
Harry these two one of them said to me
I've never seen two brothers that close
now their relationship definitely took a
big downturn when Harry left the Army
came into civilian life and essentially
had it rubbed into his face that things
had changed he was now very much the
number two his brother was on the path
to be king that was painful for him to
behold because there's only two years
between them and Diana had raised them
the same
but that was when it began to really
curdle when he understood finally felt
as opposed to new notionally that he was
the number two that made him very bitter
but he's he's definitely kind of
rewriting history in the path of their
relationship
is it selling out the family Tina if
you've said look I've tried to talk to
them privately about the harm that he
believes has been caused and then the
story is leaked and it's negative about
you I'm fascinated by the the belief
that he's selling out his family when he
says that he has tried privately to work
behind the scenes and nothing ever
changes
well I know he says that but he can
never give any concrete examples this is
what's frustrating I mean let's hear
some examples Harry
um uh I mean it may well be in the book
which we have not yet read so I don't
want to say that and find that all those
stories are there but so far he hasn't
really been able to give us concrete
examples of stories that he says are
about him trying to make amends and them
leaking it I I think if that's true
that's that's terrific and horrible and
and wrong I'm not suggesting that the
palace haven't done their own you know
evil work in leaking and planting I'm
sure they have they all do but frankly
you know the last Netflix documentary
that they did was a six you know part
infomercial for themselves it was all
their version nobody he keeps saying
that you know his own story and he
hasn't been told it's been nothing but
his story we've actually not heard their
story at all and we still haven't
to another coronation is May 6 do you
think he will still be included in that
I think they're going to ask him because
I think they're very careful the moment
to try to give Harry no further reasons
to go on another Grudge and all quite
honestly which is what he does I mean if
you don't they don't ask him then that's
another fuel for yet another infomercial
about how look how mean they are to me
so yeah he'll be asked whether he'll
play a big role I don't know but I'd
like I think everyone would like to see
this family reunite it's a it's a
painful thing to see these Petty fights
in public
I do I do think people really want to
see them reconcile however however they
can do that Tina thank you thank you for
your time thank you safe travels don't
forget to come back thank you